You had recommended cleansine for Tim three per day based on the last
cheek swab. Initially, just gave it to him one per meal along with other
supplements, gave him diarrhea. So now we're giving separated from meals. Should
it be separate? You don't have to take that separate, but you know what I think
about the physiology of it probably might work better separated. So remember the
cleansine is the oxygenated magnesium. So cleansine though it does have
astrozyme in it, which all the US enzyme products have astrozyme in it, even
though the astrozyme, which is their proprietary enzyme, is not really... you're
not taking the product for the astrozyme. You know, it's just helping the product
work better and the active ingredient work better. The active ingredient
in cleansine is the oxygenated magnesium. And I spoke about this a few
zoom calls ago that the Harvard scientist who has the patents on oxygenated
magnesium, the only company that uses his full proprietary utilization of his
patents is the US enzyme. So there's other oxygenated magnesiums out there,
but they're not using his full patent in formula, which they're not getting the
benefits. And so what's the purpose of oxygenated magnesium is that you're...
it will kill pathogens in your gut and it has the potential of killing
tumors in your gut as well. So that's what tested
fortune last time. So maybe it might be better to take that out of empty stomach.
He's got three different enzymes, one to help digest food, one to eat
of the tumor, and now this cleansine that we don't know what it's for.
So I'll show you a few other enzymes.